I know people probably bring this song
applaud but I love it cuz I feel like it
pertains to me but all about that bass
was kind of your first big huge song and
it's very body positive and I feel like
you like a body positive anthem I feel
like we're kind of similar in that
what's your favorite right now oh man
there are so many like nowadays I mean
that was my thing all about the bass I
wrote it because I didn't have one
growing up like obviously there was some
out there but I didn't have like a
special one but nowadays man isn't that
crazy though and now the song that you
wrote is that for yeah so many people
and I wrote it like not thinking anyone
would hear it so I really wrote it like
I wish I thought like this and then I
saw how it affected everyone I was like
oh the world needs this oh let's do
eight of these like let's keep going
yeah speaking of new music I'm very
excited I know you have a new album
coming out treat myself which I love the
album I think it's amazing but it also
has a lot of female empowerment songs
right yes it does I had like three one
is a very special to me it's called
working on it because like the hardest
part I think about today especially with
social media is like you know everyone's
like just be confident like that's the
worst thing that I've ever heard cuz
like it's so hard to be confident it so
hard to turn it on and be confident and
I wrote this one song with my two girls
it's about how when someone compliments
you and you're like oh stop it you know
how like we all do that really yeah what
do you mean and I'm working on it it's
called working on it and it's about like
I'm gonna start to try to be more
confident and start to love myself and
start to hear comments and be like yeah
that's right yeah I think that's the
hardest part because I'm super
self-deprecating yeah it was the best
thing that people are like like it's
funny but like at the end of the day
like take the compliment we want to
compliment so it's really nice and like
today when I was glamming up for 3 hours
talking about myself and I was like am I
the prettiest girl ever iron you start
saying as a joke and now I like believe
it and I'm like I'm a doll like I'm a
dork
if you say that
I always called my hair makeup team
Harry Potter because like I was so
different and I walk out and I'm like
it's this babe it's like what like
people don't want to take pics of me I
get it confused he feels like he's
cheating on ya there's like a completely
different universe
speaking of husbands you're a newlywed
[Applause]
no not yet it's not hard hits so perfect
cuz you're a newlywed I know I get there
I was like oh yeah like yeah it's fresh
and perfect and every day is better I
got a foot massage last night he woke me
up and got my favorite coffee was in the
fridge he's a different kind of species
though look that's my husband he
literally gave me my saw a foot massage
he had there not my feet weird and he
woke me up with coffee I tweeted about
it I would say no way
we got good ones yeah very second you
also sync together right he sings on
some of your songs I mean yeah he does
all day all day all do cuz I like time
to go out get a choir so they're my
choir and they're so good and yeah for
an audition yesterday he actually sang
an entire cover of a song and we were
all laughing cuz it was like really good
and I did his background so work you I
did hear a song and I bring this up
because I feel like I have the worst
ugly cry in the world but I hear that
you wrote a song called ugly cry about
Darrell he's only cried like three times
in our relationship but when it happens
it's so tough to look at straight like
it's also like we're fighting and then
I'm like really you're just gonna cry it
out right now and what is face but his
face gets like this whole different type
of human being that I'm like what is
that
I - I want to believe it looks like
Rachel McAdams from the notebook but it
doesn't the one tear looks like mommy's
ear is he's like the worst point in the
movie like it's just like bad so I wrote
a song yes the the day after that and
was like you look ugly when you cry ugly
when you cry and it was like I recorded
it and he was like nice
you're a solid relationship when she can
write a song called I love working
together all right can I can I see your
ugly cries uh-oh
he did it he hid the matter of that's it
but it's pretty ugly it's okay spaz I
hate when you cry on camera for like
movies and stuff don't do that one like
I was like with them like let's find a
pretty cry okay you are like my husband
and I'm like Daryl very reverse cuz I'm
the one we start crying love you too
together you complete me I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this